et vous croyez vous aux fantômes au pays
de galles les propriétaires d'un vieux
manoir ont trouvé le filon pour
restaurer leurs propriétés et les
organise régulièrement des chasse aux
zombies spectre et autres ectoplasme au
pays de galles le reportage de yann
fossurier et olivier palomino c'est une
vieille demeure du xviie siècle perdu
dans la campagne galloise
si on en croit le folklore local
le manoir de plastique serait hanté par
des fantômes depuis plus de 200 ans
cette mystérieuse bâtisse a été restauré
il ya une vingtaine d'années la
propriétaire y accueille aujourd'hui des
amateurs de paranormal venus de toute la
grande-bretagne des chasseurs
d'ectoplasmes comme china et ses amis
faites attention c'est très sombre et si
ils ont formé un club et visitent
régulièrement ce manoir les week-ends la
nuit de préférence
ils recherchent inlassablement des
indices qui confirmeraient la présence
de fantômes
bardé d'instruments électroniques il
mesure les ondes électromagnétiques et
surveille les variations de température
j'ai relevé des fluctuations importantes
mon thermomètre indique et 18° et demi
dans cet endroit reculé laissant du sm
avant de remonter à 22 avec leur
appareil photo équipé de lasers et de
lampes à infrarouge des épaules pense
avoir saisi quelque chose ce soir dans
ce couloir
c'est ce cliché qui a retenu mon
attention car je me demande encore ce
qui a pu causer cette sorte de halo
inhabituel je n'avais jamais vu quelque
chose comme ça
plusieurs visiteurs disent avoir aperçu
dans ce manoir les spectres de deux
enfants est celui d'une jeune femme
allait gêner montrez-vous jamais
christine entre en méditation
elle tente d'établir un contact avec ses
esprits qui entrait le manoir sous le
regard dubitatif de ce jeune couple qui
les a accompagné ce soir je suis plutôt
sceptique mais on ressent vraiment
quelque chose de spécial ici c'est
excitant
ces chasseurs de fantômes accepte qu'on
les suive la nuit dans le manoir de
plastique à condition de payer 60 euros
un chien car ce manoir a besoin d'argent
pour être maintenu en l'état
alors quand nous organisons des visites
il
l'argent collecté est entièrement
reversé à leurs propriétaires
la propriétaire des lieux est une femme
discrète elle n'apparaît jamais lors de
ces safaris du paranormal
elle dit ne pas croire aux fantômes